sur le papier il était bien ficelé ce
plan de relance européen 750 milliards
d'euros pour lutter contre la crise
provoquée par l'ico vide une sacrée
somme à la hauteur des dommages causés
une union européenne forte qui répond
présent face à ce qui est sans doute
l'un des plus grands défis de son
histoire récente
sauf que bah ça a coincé et en hongrie
et la pologne ont posé leur veto
soutenue ensuite par la slovénie et ont
donc enrayer toute la belle machine
européenne qui après une crise sanitaire
une crise financière gut maintenant à la
crise diplomatique
miam en fait les pays s'opposent à une
petite clause en bas du contrat tout
petit le respect obligatoire de l'état
de droit
question que me direz vous eh bien on
sait pas trop mais en fait sur le papier
ce serait des règles qui pourraient
sembler basique comme un processus
d'adoption des lois transparent des
tribunaux indépendants et impartiaux la
séparation des pouvoirs où la liberté de
la presse
c'est un manquement à l'état de droit
est observé par le conseil de l'union
européenne formée par les états membres
l'attribution des fonds européens
pourraient être suspendus
la pologne et surtout la hongrie qui ont
notamment des politiques plus ferme sur
l'immigration par exemple craignent donc
de se retrouver et puniques qu'on leur
retire les fonds européens ou qu'ils
perdent leur souveraineté
liberté d'agir comme ils le souhaitent
dans leur pays du côté europe dit que ce
principe est avant tout là pour
contrôler l'utilisation de ces fonds
financé par le contribuable européen le
a en tout cas déjà annoncé qu'ils
allaient essayer de contourner ces veto
et ainsi pouvoir se passer de l'accord
de la pologne et de la hongrie
[Musique]